what's going on guys this is rob and for
those of you guys who have been
following this channel for a little
while that we usually stick to an upload
schedule where we upload on mondays and
thursdays on mondays we cover pop
culture icons so like people
events different things like that and
then on thursdays or fridays we cover
wand division or some other kind of pop
culture tv show that's popular after one
division is over but i want to make an
exception
today i want to talk about why this
scarlet witch
or wanda maximoff is not only more
powerful than doctor strange
she's actually more powerful than the
infinity gauntlet if not as powerful as
the infinity gauntlet and here's the
reason why this is a really really good
case to be made here
just based on the things that we've seen
in one division so the idea is that in
marvel comics you've got differing
people with differing levels of power
not everybody has the same level of
power even when we start looking at
people who can alter reality
at different scales so say for example
we took the son of reed richards a kid
by the name of franklin richards his
power is
insane right he can alter reality he can
do all kinds of crazy stuff
but franklin richards is not as powerful
as somebody like
the molecule man owen reese when he was
at his absolute prime
and the reason why is because franklin
richards is called a universal shaper
he's able to manipulate reality on a
universal level the molecule man owen
reese was a multiversal character he
could alter reality on the multiversal
level you look at somebody like protege
he was the exact same way that molecule
man owen reese was the difference was
that protege could copy the powers of
other people and there was no upper
limit to the powers he could copy
right so it was kind of nuts how
powerful he got as time went on
now if you guys don't know who franklin
richards or the molecule man
or protege are it's not a great huge
deal down in the description you'll find
a link to videos that i've made over on
the comics explained channel that
emphasizes
super powerful characters and what makes
them so powerful but the nature of
somebody like doctor strange
is that he basically borrows powers and
you guys have probably figured that out
by watching the the doctor strange film
that stephen strange has no abilities
unto himself
it's not as though when he was training
with the ancient one that he had these
powers inside of his mind that were
unlocked instead the way this works is
you have
all kinds of magical beings that exist
out there and they basically
lend their power to steven strange so
when you guys were watching the events
of infinity war and you saw that great
big huge battle with like dr strange and
iron man and those guys when dr strange
shot out those red bands those are
called the crimson bands of sidorak
sidorak is the same guy who gave the
juggernaut his powers in marvel comics a
brunt of doctor strange's power is
something like 80 percent
basically comes from a group called the
vashanti it's actually three individuals
and there came a point in marvel comics
when doctor strange was asked to
participate in
a war that was going on on the astral
level and the result was that steven
strange turned it down
he basically said no following that the
vashanti took away
all the power they gave him which took
away something like 80 of his power they
gave it back eventually
but he only got a fraction of it back so
he was a lot weaker than he had been in
years past but that's how all that works
but at any point in time any one of
these magical beings can just cut doctor
strange off to that source of power and
he'll be weaker as a result of it but
regardless of how you slice it the very
core of steven strange's power comes
down to something called
matter manipulation meaning that in its
current form stephen strange can do all
kinds of wonky stuff but the things he
can do
is relative to the tangible universe
right so if we take something like a
coffee cup for example right you take a
little coffee cup
steven strange can break that coffee cup
down on the atomic level and then you
can take atoms from other things you can
take adam from the air he can take atoms
from the water he can take atoms from a
brick wall he can merge those with the
coffee cup and create a wholly new
object that's maybe like a dog or like a
human being
or any number of things he can do all
kinds of stuff but he can control matter
on the atomic level and that's where his
power stops with somebody like the
scarlet witch she's on a
whole different level now and the reason
why is because we've seen her rewind
time
we've seen her just make things appear
out of thin air the scarlet witch is
what you refer to
as a reality manipulator meaning she's
not bound by the laws of physics and
she's not bound by the atomic makeup of
everything
in the universe that she can basically
create something out of nothing
so if she wanted to turn that coffee cup
into something else she doesn't have to
pull
atoms from other objects and then
incorporate those into the coffee cup
and then give it a new form
she just snaps your fingers and it
becomes something else right it's a
whole different level of power it's very
similar to what the infinity gauntlet
does the infinity gauntlet allows the
wielder to manipulate the very forces of
the universe itself but the way that
things get kind of crazy here and this
is why the scarlet witch is so far
beyond doctor strange at the moment is
because when you take
something like the infinity gauntlet
you're able to use it only to achieve
various
ends but you're still required to use it
to pull those things off so like
somebody like stephen strange for
example could manipulate time but he had
to have the time stone to do it
wanda doesn't need any of those things
wanda is in and of herself by virtue of
her own power
manipulating time space and the universe
she is
the most the single most powerful being
in all of existence
in the in the marvel cinematic universe
right now now
how that'll change as time goes on we
don't fully know and that's why a lot of
people who are talking about mephisto in
wanda vision that's why it's so
intriguing for them because mephisto's
one of these guys where his power
changes based on how long he's away from
his home dimension right he's one of the
hell lords we've talked about that
before that the realm of hell is kind of
divided up
among various individuals and mephisto
is the most powerful
inside of his own realm but if he leaves
the realm of hell the longer he's away
the weaker he becomes but if he were for
example to like immediately leave hell
and then show right up to wanda and
start talking to her he'd be insanely
powerful
how it is mephisto would compare it to
the power that wanda has i would say he
could probably still be defeated wand is
just on that level of power now
it's a little crazy because the marvel
cinematic universe is shifting from
some things up and they're changing
things so we don't really know how the
power of the characters in the comics
will scale to the movies but i just want
to make a quick video kind of addressing
that right because i've seen people
asking the question
who's more powerful the marvel cinematic
universe version of wanda
or the marvel cinematic universe version
of doctor strange and right now it's
wanda
the biggest issue that you have i think
with her character is that her power is
not necessarily regulated or controlled
in the sense that she doesn't know how
to utilize it in the most finite ways
the same way that doctor strange does
she can do some pretty fine strokes
right like creating things out of
nothing
moving things with her mind stuff like
that but as we've seen over the course
of wanda vision if she loses her focus
she loses control over her powers right
so she's not that well trained and how
to use her abilities it's pretty bare
bones right
it's pretty basic in terms of how she
goes but the raw power the raw ability
to basically manipulate reality to
control the very forces of reality to
make something out of nothing
she is on that level right now by all
standards of measurement she's what you
would define as a god
that's really how you would define her
in in really in any way
you know that's kind of the the name
that you would give her so i just wanted
to address that real quick i thought
it'd be kind of a cool talking point
here you know it's it's one of these
things where we don't really know if
it'll last that long but i think that's
really where one division becomes so
intriguing because what we know from
like the conversation that the ancient
one
had with bruce banner during the events
of avengers in game is that whenever you
have a timeline
no matter how small the adjustment that
you make to that timeline you'll create
a separate timeline right so what you'll
what you're most likely seeing
in or at least what you probably will
see in the multiverse of madness is what
happens as a result of all the changes
that wand has made
that while they are small changes in
scale relative to the size of the
universe the result is that they have a
cascading effect so maybe somebody was
supposed to be somewhere at a certain
point in time right monica rambo was
supposed to be at a particular
location when a certain event was
supposed to take place but because of
what wanda is doing monaco's there
instead and it has this great big huge
cascading effect where a single
super important event's supposed to
happen and monica's not there and then
everything pops off
right like what if tony stark never took
the infinity stones away from thanos
that kind of an effect right i'm not
really saying that as a as an example
i'm just saying as a general principle
that's what we're talking about here the
butterfly effect is what people also
call it that's probably what the
multiverse of madness is going to come
out of the fact that juan has made these
small changes that basically ripple out
into these huge changes and affect the
entirety of the multiverse and things
just start going crazy
and who knows what's gonna happen after
that right it's gonna be absolutely
bonkers and so circling back around to
the main point of the video i guess the
real question to ask here is with
everything going on
in wanda vision and everything that
we've just talked about if steven
strange shows up
and tries to stop wanda will there be
anything he can do
and my answer would be no there'd be no
way for steven strange to stop
wanda maximoff because even if he has
all these little nuanced abilities
in his possession in terms of just sheer
raw magical power he just doesn't seem
to be on the same level that she is but
it is the mcu
and we have seen how things wax and lane
so in the end only time will tell
but anyway guys if you want to get
caught up on the videos that we have
with wandavision make sure you guys
click the videos here at the end screen
uh get caught up on all of our theories
all the little easter eggs things that
we found
applying our comic book knowledge to one
division and teaching you things that
you probably didn't know and i will
catch you all later peace